alors dans les salles cette semaine et
notamment aussi 17 le très très beau
film d'animation que j'ai eu la chance
de voir à cannes de zabou breitman et je
ne veux pas écorché son nom
et les à gober mais vv qui s'appelle les
hirondelles de kaboul dont c'est une
adaptation d'un roman de yasmina khadra
et ça me plonge en 1998 à kaboul ville
qui vient d'être soi disant libérer du
joug russe par les talibans et où on
assiste évidemment à mon espèce de
terreur qu'ils installent des exécutions
sommaires etc etc et on va suivre
l'histoire de deux personnages
principaux deux jeunes afghans qui
s'appelle à mohsen est une erreur qui
sont plein d'utopie plein de rêves et
qui cherchent à vivre leur amour
tranquillement fait tranquillement le
plus tranquillement possible dans kaboul
jusqu'au jour où bruxelles va commettre
l'irréparable je vous en dis pas plus
donc c'est à découvrir nos salles c'est
un très très beau film d'animation qui
fait penser rs et célestine puisque et
léa a travaillé sur le film
ernest et célestine donc c'est très très
fluide c'est très très beau très très
belle musique aussi donc vraiment
n'hésitez pas à court et et ne soyez pas
rebutés par le fait que ce soit un film
d'animation est aussi avoir dans nos
salles deux mois le la dernière
livraison de cédric klapisch très réussi
[Musique]